what would have meant for you to see a
Latina Cover Girl or someone out there
that did look like you growing up
it would have been so much
told me that like I too yeah am
beautiful you know and and not just
um
uh you know growing up with the same
sort of images of what an American woman
looks like you know and I I'm American
I'm born and raised in America you know
what American Beauty is and what it
means and this is the only home I know
it's the only country that I can claim
as as my home and and and so to feel
reflected in that to feel seen to to
feel appreciated and valued you know as
a young person you're obviously not
aware of all the messages you're
receiving but you're you're eating them
up and and they add up to how we see
ourselves and what we think is possible
for us and you know
um I think beauty standards uh
unfortunately currently take a
disproportionate amount of young women's
energy you know we spend a lot of time
trying to meet somebody else's standard
of beauty which I think has nothing to
do with actually feeling beautiful
because I you know I look at pictures of
myself where objectively
that's a beautiful dress that's
beautiful hair that's beautiful makeup I
you know with some distance I can say oh
that woman looks beautiful but I can
tell you that I didn't feel beautiful
so what's the point why does it matter
if if we're trying to meet sort of
superficial external expectations but on
the inside there's something telling us
we're not good enough we don't belong
we're still a little to this or a little
to that and if I was just a little more
of this and a little less of that then
maybe I would belong and it really is
all about belonging it's we want to
belong we want to know that we deserve
to be where we are and we deserve to be
valued and so for me that's what my
journey with Beauty has been about it's
about getting to a place where I where I
feel my beauty which I think is so much
more important than anything else well
said and your mom have you redefine what
beauty is now do you approach it
differently
I mean yes I mean you know
I think that we have so many examples
now
of of women and men who refuse to play
inside of the lines right to color
inside of these very narrowly defined
lines about what is beautiful and and
it's giving us all permission I think
when we see people claiming themselves
as beautiful their uniqueness as
beautiful it gives us all permission to
to to love exactly who we are the way
that we are and and so I think that's
the new definition of beauty and and
that was a journey for me to get there
personally and I love being a part of
the larger conversation to help more of
us get there with less struggle wow and
talk about conversation you put a post
on up that said the story behind the
smile girl this one talked to every
mother out there I have two daughters
but yes we need to prioritize ourselves
yes we need time for ourselves I mean uh
what do you do when you feel overwhelmed
and having some of that anxiety what do
you do for yourself now
well
you know I think that one of the
one of the smallest and easiest tricks
at any given moment is to just
be kinder to yourself you know that post
that you're talking about on Instagram
you know it comes from
from feeling like I'm failing at taking
care of myself so not only am I not
taking not finding the time to take care
of myself but now I'm feeling like I'm a
failure at self-care which is like
fail here and it's like who needs that
like before where we are making
ourselves feel worse because we can't
find time to make ourselves feel better
and and you know in that and what I
realized now is that at any given moment
the one kind thing I can do for myself
is to go easier on myself so to not
treat myself with such expectations
um that that mean I'm constantly failing
at something you know and I think
moms and women we want to be everything
to everyone all the time and it's just
not possible but we're I feel like I'm
at a point where it's like I want to be
a lot of things I want to do a lot of
things and I'm not going to get to each
one of those things every single day and
and today I got to be a really good mom
and a and really good at my job but I
didn't really get to be good to myself
and you know what
that's okay and tomorrow it'll be a
different mixture of the many things I
want to be and and that that has to be
okay because we're all trying our best
and the last thing we need is to go hard
on ourselves it's so true and there's no
such thing as balance either right it's
one day it's the family one day it's
your job when it's you know there's that
you just gotta go with it and whatever
that priority is which is so true what
you're saying and you're the the face of
Covergirl fresh clean fresh skin care
line which is absolutely amazing why was
this the perfect fit for you oh my gosh
it's so exciting for me I mean first of
all like I have to since I was 17 I've
been in makeup more days of my life than
not right okay 5 a.m whether it's a day
on set whether it's a press day what
have you so you know makeup
and and taking care of my skin was a
work thing you know and so in my
personal life I really wanted to rest I
wanted to not wear the makeup I wanted
to just look and feel as much myself and
also to really let my skin rest because
wearing that much makeup all day every
day
um as a part of my job you know is a lot
it's a it's a lot on my skin and so so
keeping my skin clean and fresh and
glowy has always been for me like my
number one like Beauty priority is like
keep my skin looking great because when
I'm not in full hair and makeup I want
to feel good you know and
um so so skin care has always been sort
of my beauty yeah
so the fact that I I was invited to be a
cover girl and then and then to get to
be the face of the Skin Care launch is
so perfect and authentic to me and what
I care about when it comes to Beauty so
how much do you love the weightless
water cream
it's so great I mean my mine is like
everything feels like velvet everything
is soft everything goes on like a hug
like a pillow Latin pillow it's
beautiful
um it's really fun to use there's this
amazing glow Mist that I use several
times a day because it just feels good
and then and then again it leaves you
feeling hydrated it's like it's like how
much do you hear in our culture like
hydrate hydrate hydrate yeah
I mean I I have a water bottle this big
standing down like this
inspirational things too yeah I meant no
excuses at this point but
hours behind I've had a few cups of
coffee so it's like hydrate dehydrated
anyway hydration is really important
to everything obviously from the inside
drink water but also anything that like
helps me feel and look hydrated on the
outside I love and that's the whole
that's the whole skincare line um it's
it's all so hydrating and moisturizing
and and just feels glowy and natural
when you found out you were going to be
a cover girl who's the first person you
told
well I mean my husband probably
did you ever think you'd be married to a
Cover Girl
and he was just like whatever
I was like you've got to write that one
it's like you invested well
um definitely I told my husband first
and then
um
and you know my sister who is only like
a year older than me which I think she
just kind of laughed because it's funny
I mean part of it is fun because you
know it's it's really surreal to like
yeah grow up
you know
um really idolizing
um
certain brands that are just they're
they're just iconic they're they're
archetypal you know and and to and to
um to get to be a part of that
conversation
um as the person that I actually am you
know not not oh I I dyed my hair the
right color and I and my skin finally is
doing the thing that I wanted to and I'm
the perfect size and weight and you know
I strove and I strobe and now I fit in
the box and I made it like
that isn't what this is this is I didn't
change the narrative has changed and the
narrative
and to be able to find Space inside of
that narrative is is really
I think is Monumental for for so I mean
for me personally obviously because I
never imagined it but I think for the
culture at large you know to to start
seeing new
new images of of Who belongs and who is
worthy and who has value
um in big ways and in small ways
um it it really it makes a difference
and so this is you know it's it's all a
little bit of a of a Dream It's a dream
and it's a beautiful dream and on top of
that you were so busy I mean you created
hentify which is such an amazing
authentic show you directed it you
executive produced it I mean talking
about change is Shifting and making this
happen like it must be surreal that you
were able to do such a project
like hentified yeah oh yeah no that was
amazing you know it's
you know I think part of it is the
narratives are shifting and the work is
on us to shift them they don't just bend
we have to do the bending and so it's
been a lot of work and you know I've I
started my career 20 years ago
um I was 17 years old I was grateful to
be in the room thrilled and excited and
never imagined how much
the the cultural narrative would shift
but also how much work there is for each
and every single one of us to be a part
of that change that change is not
inevitable that it has to be a choice
and there's a lot of work that goes into
creating new stories and getting the
opportunity to tell new stories so it is
really important when
it is really important when we get those
opportunities when large Studios or
networks or massive Brands like
Covergirl aren't just saying they want
to change the story but they're actually
making the choice to put their money and
their brand and their investment where
that conversation lies and say we're
going to be a part of changing this and
and it's a lot of work and there's
nothing easy about it and it can't be
taken for granted
um and we never did take it for granted
on hentified for it to be a series that
was created by these two latinx writers
that created opportunity for latinx
talent in front of the camera behind the
camera every single level of production
a camera DP ads wardrobe hair makeup you
know all of it the the the Ripple
effects of creating new opportunity and
putting new kinds of people in positions
of power and positions to create and
positions to define the story it is it's
hard it's hard to get there and once
you're there none of it can be taken for
granted and it and it does it creates a
small
Ripple that that that has more impact
than I think anyone will ever truly get
to quantify you just have to know that
that you've done your part to change
this story and it will reach and touch
the people that it's meant to